- This is one of those costumes
where my grandparents will somehow
find this on the internet
and give me a call like,
"What are you doing with your life?"
(swooshing)
(creaking sign)
(upbeat music)
- I love Halloween.
It's my favorite holiday.
Aurora doesn't like Halloween.
- I just, like, never had
like the best Halloween experience.
- I'm obsessed with Halloween.
- There's a stronger word than obsessed.
We met at a Halloween party.
Jen's, like, got a little
- [Jen] (laughs)
- [Steven] stupid water gun
and this giant grin on her face.
I was, like, "Alright.
"I kinda respect that."
- So we've only had
one Halloween together.
I was a diva, and I was Cruella de Vil,
and Tyler graciously was a dalmation.
- [Tyler] I was a dalmation.
She tells me what I'm gonna wear.
She holds me to this standard of costume,
and I deliver.
(funky orchestral music)
- I chose Khaleesi from Game of Thrones,
so Daenerys Targaryen.
Khaleesi is strong,
powerful, and assertive,
which I think Safiya can identify with.
But she's also pretty high maintenance
and pretty queeny.
Safiya can be those things, too.
- I chose a Cat Woman outfit for her
because, you know, I'm a nerd.
Cat Woman's always trying to be sensual,
and Aurora's just more
down to earth and chill,
so it'd be fun to see. (laughs)
- I thought, like, immediately back to,
which, maybe was my sexual awakening.
In the movie Space Jam,
Lola Bunny was hot!
Cute, but like, sassy.
Had an attitude.
I think Jen has a lot of those qualities.
(funky orchestral music)
- I'm nervous because I
asked Steve for a clue
and he said it's a character or person
he had a crush on when he was younger.
He's told me stories about
hoarding Victoria Secret
magazines. (laughs)
- I think he probably chose something
I wouldn't normally dress up as.
I would be up for dressing up as
like an elf or a fairy.
- I think it's either like
a classic historical costume
or it's like, Dany,
like Daenerys Targaryen.
(funky orchestral music)
- Oh, my God, I think I was right.
Is it Dany?
Whenever Tyler wants to
make fun of me being high maintenance,
he does the like, "Where are my dragons?"
- This is from, uh, what's that movie,
Space Jams? (laughs)
A lot of skin.
- He chose something sexy.
It's some character from the Dark Knight,
which I have not seen.
Oh, it's Cat Woman, huh?
I'm so slow to these things.
(drumming)
- This feels pretty fun, actually.
- There seem to be, uh, two sets of holes.
One is for my arms and
the other is for, um,
the sides of my torso or my boobs?
- I would totally rock
this if I had a few drinks.
- I feel pretty tough in this.
Things might get a little dangerous.
- The wig is on. (laughs)
- Sorry, Mom and Dad.
- I could mount a dragon in this costume.
(upbeat music)
(growling like a cat)
(laughs)
(laughing)
- Alright.
- [Aurora] Meow, meow.
- [Ify] Okay.
- [Aurora] I think this is actually
what you were going for, Babe.
(upbeat music)
(laughs)
- I feel like I need a basketball.
(claps)
(laughs)
- Wow, look at that.
You look like you could play basketball.
You could ball in that.
(upbeat music)
- Ah! (laughs)
- There's a lot of holes, Babe.
- Oh, shoot.
Yikes!
- You knew that!
- I basically just turned her
into a Playboy Bunny.
(bleep)
(laughs)
- It took me a minute to figure out
what this costume was,
but I'm pretty excited to be Halle Berry.
- That's the bad Cat Woman.
- Oh.
- You are Anne Hathaway, Cat Woman.
- She's doing Cat Woman?
- Well, you have to retie me.
- See, look at this.
She's ordering me around.
- Retie it,
- If Safiya wore this
for too long,
- [Safiya] Commoner
we might be in a dangerous situation.
- No, none of that.
Cat Woman never twiddles
her fingers at Batman.
- Well, this is Cat Woman
with an Aurora spin.
You're aware of that?
- Okay, yeah.
- This is great.
Let's get ready to rumble.
- [Jen] (laughs)
- Halloween this year might
be a little different.
This was really fun.
I like my costume of
being a cat person, woman,
woman cat, Cat Woman.
- I'm gonna cross this off my bucket list,
but,
- [Jen] Do I
need to get you a sock?
(laughs)
(claps)
- Whoa!
- What do you think, baby?
You like it, right?
See, look at this!
She loves this.
(laughs)
- Me ow, me ow.
Oh, my God.
We could do Cat Woman and Batman one year.
- Yeah, yeah, we could definitely do that.
- Mmmmm.
(laughs)
(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] Where is she?
Where is she?
(swooshing)
(creaking sign)